هل من تفاصيل اكثر حول هذا الصاروخ او هذه
الصواريخ التي اطلقت باتجاه المدمره والتي
تقول الجهات الامريكيه بانه تم
اسقاطها سمير هل
تسمعني اسمع ممكن تعيد السؤال ام سالتك عن
التفاصيل ان وجدت بالاضافه الى ما ذكرناه
عن استهداف هذه المدمره والذي قالت
القياده الوسطى الامريكيه بان بانها اسقطت
هذا
الصاروخ نعم هو ياتي في سلسله التصعيد
التي تقوم بها جماعه انصار الله ضد القوات
الامريكيه والبريطانيه الموجوده في خليج
عدن وكذلك البحرين الاحمر والبحر العربي
بيان الناطق اشار الى ان الاستهداف اليوم
تم على هذه المدمره في في خليج عدن وجاء
بعد ايام فقط من استهداف ايضا سفينه
عسكريه امريكيه واستهداف ايضا المدمره
الامريكيه الموجوده في خليج عدن هي الاخرى
وتاتي ايضا ضمن سلسله من التصعيد المستمر
الذي اعلنه زعيم الجماعه عبد الملك الحوثي
بان اسلحه نوعيه قد دخلت الى الخدمه
ويمكنها ان تستهدف اي سفينه امريكيه سواء
كانت موجوده في البحرين الاحمر والبحر
العربي وان قواته او قواته قادره على
استهدافها بشكل مباشر كانت ايضا جماعه
انصار الله الحوثيين قد استهدفت سفينه
نفطيه بريطانيه بشكل مباشر مما ادى الى
احتراقها في ال 26 من يناير الجاري وحسب
بيان الناطق العسكري باسم الجماعه فان
عمليه الاستهداف تتم بصواريخ بالست وهذا
هو الشيء المثير والنوعي بحسب الخبراء
العسكريون هنا بان الاستهداف بالصواريخ
البالستيه عاده ما يتم على اهداف ثابته
لكن الجماعه استطاعت بحسب بعض مصادرها هنا
تقول انها استطاعت ان تطور اسلحه مناسبه
قادره على استهداف اهداف متحرف كما هي
السفن والمدمرات الامريكيه بصواريخ
بالستيه